the main subject of my thought was that
was oil and while I was in office we
passed a massive legislation that
reverse that trend we reduced oil
imports from eight and a half million
tons per day it have been in barrels a
day to a less than half that in just
five years but now we've almost doubled
what we had to begin with so we're still
heavily dependent on other nations for
not only goods but also money now every
time we spend a dollar that we don't
have we have to borrow 40 cents of it
for instance from a Chinese to balance
our budget just by going deeper and
deeper in debt we've become increasingly
addicted to consumption of goods that we
don't produce ourselves and a lot of the
manufacturing has gone overseas and this
is so in the last few years it's been
not just handwork products like shirts
and and shoes and clothing but it's
become the advanced cutting-edge
technological products for instance when
I was in office we had the preeminent
position in the production of
alternative sources of energy windmills
and photovoltaic cells things of that
kind
now that a Senate say has moved to China
China is the number one producer of new
kinds of advanced photovoltaic cells for
instance and they are the number one
producers of advanced windmills but to
utilize powerfulness Sun and directive
to the wind so we've lost that edge that
we used to have in scientific innovation
applications to to goods to be sold in
many ways that's also changing in the
electronic field almost all of the
materials that we use now of an advanced
tech technology I haven't and iPad and
also an iPod both of which are made in
China although we have designed them
here with Apple first and so they're
manufactured overseas